by travelpod member
Oh
bye
No
Oh
member
welcome to the class case ceremony
celebrating the accomplishments of the
class of 2009 of Columbia School of
general studies
I'm especially pleased that President
Lee Bollinger provost Alan Brinkley
executive vice president nicholas dirks
dean shelly schwartz and members of the
faculty and administration are here to
share in our celebration I would also
like to welcome our class day speaker
mr. philippe reinas graduate of the
class of two thousand finally it is my
privilege to welcome our reunion classes
spanning 60 years and especially warm
welcome goes to mrs. Helen Everts class
of nineteen seventy and tireless
advocate for GS students and alumni
helen is one of the recipients this year
of the alumni metal which will be
awarded at commencement on Wednesday the
faculty of Columbia University is
committed to the ideal that an Ivy
League education should be available to
talented women and men at any point in
their lives whether our students are
dancers entrepreneurs or firefighters
whether they are in the challenging
joint program witless college of the
Jewish Theological Seminary working
parents or professional musicians
whether they are international students
or new Americans they received the same
superb education as all Columbia
undergraduates since he assumed the
presidency of Columbia in 2002 Lee
Bollinger has articulated ID on a
dynamic vision for the future of this
great University and mobilized the human
and financial resources required to
transform that vision into reality in
the past seven years president Bollinger
has skillfully
to completion the approval process for
Columbia's ambitious expansion into
manhattanville in West Harlem he
continues to enhance scientific research
with the promise of a major center for
neuroscience one of the first new
buildings in Manhattan Ville president
Bollinger has moved Columbia University
into the forefront of international
universities with the establishment of
Columbia centers in Beijing China and
Amman Jordan with additional centers to
be open soon in Africa and India and
other parts of the world he has focused
the university's priorities on improving
even further undergraduate education
witnessed by the appointment of dr.
Michelle moody Adams at the new Dean of
Columbia College and vice president for
undergraduate education and the
appointment of dr. Claude Steele as the
new Provost of the University Lee
Bollinger is also a committed educator
continuing to teach an undergraduate
course on the First Amendment even while
he leads this great University it is my
privilege to introduce to you the 19th
president of Columbia University Lee
Bollinger
thank you very much Peter and let me on
behalf of all of us thank you for what
you do as dean of general studies this
is a tremendous person and a tremendous
service that he performs for all of us
and we're very very grateful Peter
and you will have to sit and listen to
me at some length on Wednesday so I
promise to be very brief you clapping
for the brevity part or the you have to
listen to me on Wednesday so I just want
to say to you a kind of congratulations
there is no group that will graduate
from columbia today or in the next
several days that more embodies the
spirit of what education really is then
you you're the most diverse class in the
Ivy League in every possible way you
have people from a 17-2 age 65 socially
economically you're the most diverse
you're a hell of a group and it is it is
most of all I think to all of us the
sense that your heart is the purest for
education of anybody here at Columbia
that is we know that you came here
because you wanted an education it
wasn't just a course in life that you
were on and you've succeeded and you
succeeded brilliantly for us as faculty
and those of us in the administration
that means a very great deal so that you
epitomize what columbia stands for and
what we believe in education really is
all about so i'll see you on Wednesday
save some of your happiness for them and
I'll look forward to it congratulations
it is a particular pleasure for me to
welcome back to columbia GS alumnus
philippe reinas who in so many ways
epitomizes Columbia's commitment to
public service the leaf grew up on the
Upper West Side in the shadow of alma
mater after high school he tried college
for a semester but soon returned to New
York and worked for several years before
resuming his college education at GS
after graduation he moved to Nashville
to work on Al Gore's campaign for the
presidency whether he realized it or not
at the time his political career had
begun the year after graduation belief
was named Al Gore's teaching assistant
with the course he taught at Columbia in
2001 Philippe then served in a number of
key political positions including deputy
communications director of the New York
City Council member of the campaign team
for Council Speaker Peter Vallone run
for the mayor of New York and
communications director for California
congresswoman Jane Harman in 2003
Philippe joined senator Hillary Rodham
Clinton's team where he has remained
ever since currently Philippe is senior
adviser to the Secretary of State
Hillary Rodham Clinton and serves as the
Secretary's primary spokesperson it is a
privilege and a pleasure to introduce to
you our class day speaker Dilip reinas
Dean on thank you for that glowing
introduction and as you'll hear in a bid
it was not all as thought out as as he
made it out to be usually speakers on
days like today are chosen at the end of
their career so I hope you all don't
know something that I haven't been told
yet in any case i will try and make the
most of the 15 minutes of fame you've
afforded me here today if a decade ago
someone found me in the star library
right over there where I spent most of
my time on campus or at alis on 116 and
told me that a decade later had be here
today participating in class day of 2009
I absolutely would have believed them it
would have made complete sense to me of
course I would have assumed they meant
that I'd still be here struggling
through Chaucer or calculus to satisfy
Columbia's regulus core curriculum but
to stand here is your class day speaker
that's quite a surprise an incredible
honor so thank you again for that honor
I also agreed to speak today before
anyone told me how much the school has
grown when i graduated in two thousand
it was in lerner hall and it was
significantly smaller than the crowd
that's gathered here today so this is a
lot more exciting and overwhelming than
I anticipated and on that front I want
to congratulate the faculty the staff
and all of you at general studies for
that growth and for that success I've
often described GS as the greatest kept
secret in higher education but i guess
that secret is out speaking of which I
need a favor from all of you I need to
ask you need to ask you to help me keep
a secret of my own as some of you may
have noticed my boss secretary of state
clinton was actually standing at this
podium only a few hours ago she
addressed the the Barnard graduation I
tried to talk her out of it but I
couldn't and as she was leaving campus
she noticed that I wasn't leaving with
her she looked at me and asked aren't
you coming and I told her now I'm gonna
stay and see my mother which narrowly
speaking which was what I'm paid to do a
spokesman
is absolutely correct and truthful my
mother's here in the audience even
though I forgot to give you this I'm
sorry and I will be seeing her later I
only admitted the other thousand or 1500
view because she just would have made me
nervous she's done this a lot she's
given a lot of speeches she might have
suggested I practice in front of her I I
didn't it was more adjectives than I
needed I didn't want to go there so if
anyone happens if I've been to the
Secretary of State between now and
whenever please I remember I was not
here hopefully this will work i know
that a lot of speakers have come and
gone to climb without being noticed all
the time I remember I remember a iranian
President Mahmoud Ahmadinejad was here
and spoken and that stay pretty quiet
didn't mr. president but now that you've
agreed or hopefully agreed to do that
for me I which is basically withholding
information from a high government
officials hopefully there's something I
can bite you that's helpful as you
graduate I don't want to offer advice
instead I'd rather tell you a few
stories and the lessons they've taught
me since I left this campus as a newly
minted graduate but I don't want these
lessons to be just any ordinary lessons
because you aren't ordinary students so
i'll leave the traditional lessons to
the traditional graduates today i want
to share three experiencing experiences
where I've dispensed with the
traditional advice and what I
experienced and learned as a result the
first piece of advice of conventional
advice that i dispense with was don't
put all your eggs in one basket like
every one of you graduating today and
like those here representing GS classes
as far back as 1949 i was not a
traditional 21 year old finishing up for
title years of college as dean on said
after high school I started at SUNY
Albany where I lasted one semester
through the rest of my 20s I passed
through a couple more colleges including
Harvard Extension school where your
salutatory and Emily Holland also spent
some time attempt I worked on trading
desks at several large financial
institutions both here and and in boston
and i spent about half a year driving
across country so when i arrived
at GS in january of 1998 I was I think
the traditional poster child
non-traditional student I had about two
years of college credit that I had
transferred and leaving two years ago
which given how long it took me to do
those first two years of credit it felt
like a hundred years my my first couple
of semesters here were at night and I
continued to work during the day and
then the fall of 98 I stopped working
entirely to attend full-time which
really the first time I had done so
since first starting college for the
next five semesters including a summer
in Beijing on colombia's program I was a
full-time Columbia student and I loved
every day but except for the a ferment
sioned calculus class and by the way as
a total aside I'm sorry to say this
there is no practical use in life for
calculus none apologies to the
mathematicians behind me um when I
graduated though it may of two thousand
I was by then a few months into my 30s I
had no job I didn't even have any
interviews set up what I did have was
about a hundred thousand dollars of
student loans and a one-way plane ticket
to a city I'd never been before but I
was newly armed with something else
something that you will all be handed
shortly a degree from Columbia
University with that it seemed a natural
time to do what it always wanted to do
but for whatever reason hadn't for me
that was politics and in two thousand
the center of the political universe was
the presidential election between Vice
President Al Gore and governor george
bush and so i decided to go to the
campaign's headquarters and when I got
there I decided I wouldn't take no for
an answer I didn't have a back-up plan I
didn't have any alternatives I really
had no clue what to do with it didn't
work out so contrary to traditional
advice i went ahead and i put every
single ed egg i had in that one basket
and i took that basket to texas to work
for george w bush
I'm kidding I I went to Nashville and I
worked for Vice President Gore but at
the time I didn't know anyone working in
nashville on the camp I didn't know
anyone in democratic politics but I had
seen the war room and I had seen primary
colors and it always seemed like you
could just show up and be you know
cabinet member for you were nice so I
walked in and I volunteer I had no idea
what would come what was to come in that
historic election and my doctors
basically told me that to keep my blood
pressure down I shouldn't dwell on it
too much yes we lost but I finally did
what I wanted to do and that and that
felt very special it was the first time
I had experienced that in in my adult
life and professionally speaking every
good thing that has happened in my
career in politics stems from that
campaign no matter how it turned out or
how difficult it was so putting all my
eggs in one basket turned to be one of
the smartest things I ever I ever did I
I didn't see that time that I think it's
important to remember that as you go on
that things might not make sense as
you're doing them the second piece of
conventional the traditional advice i
dispense with was never let them see you
sweat it was 2002 when I was invited to
interview with then senator Hillary
Clinton who had an open position in her
Washington office for our spokesman I've
been working on the hill barely for six
months and I didn't think I had a shot
at the job I never worked in the clinton
white house my experience was limited to
the gore campaign and frankly I didn't
think I was particularly qualified for
the job so I went to her office suite at
the allotted time on the appointed day
and when it was time for the interview
she bounded out her personal office to
greet me with a big hi Philippe I'm
Hillary Clinton I've seen her do it a
million times since i'm not sure if any
of you've had a chance to meet her or
see her but I immediately realized she
was not the politician that she was
portrayed to be on television it was
actually as interviews goes pretty fun I
found myself really liking her and
agreeing with her with most of what she
was saying but
there was a problem and it's a schism
that remains between us to this very day
there I don't know the difference
between men and women but there's just
no room in the world that is too hot for
Hillary Clinton if you think it's hot
she wants the thing higher she keeps she
keeps her office pretty toasty I another
hand in pretty heat intolerant
thankfully this is a nice cool day this
robe would not help otherwise so the
slightest uptick in temperature I i
perspire what happened that day what
ensued in her office couldn't even be
called sweating it was just it was for
those who speak Yiddish it was
Singh it was just fun sweating like a
pig so I'm sitting there and I'm you
know trying to talk to one most famous
people in the world to convince it or
army for a job that would require me
keeping my cool no matter what and I
look like someone had just dumped a
glass of water over my head it was
really all I could think about I don't
even know what we were talking about and
and for those of you who sweat a lot
thinking about sweating does not in any
way help stop so any but at the end of
the interview she offered me a job so it
turned out not to be fine that she saw
me sweat I mean maybe it made me look
eager or maybe it meant that she hired
me just to get me the hell out of her
office whatever the reason I've been
sweating for ever since um the third
piece of traditional advice that i
dispense with them i suggest you do to
was the notion of the shortest distance
between two points is a straight line
and you know this better than anyone
here better than your families and your
friends it's completely wrong I don't
care what calculus professors say it's
just not right i I don't I don't know
what the proper geometrical term is for
what my career's been are for what I
imagine many of you have done but it was
not a straight line the the seven years
I've been with Secretary Clinton has
been very bumpy but before then it was
not an easier or clear path and none of
the jobs i have that while
Dean on described in hindsight as
sounding like they flowed naturally one
from the next they didn't necessarily
feel that way at the time but in the end
each experience helped along the way
from Nashville to City Hall in New York
to Capitol Hill in DC and everything in
between between leaving GS and the time
that I started working for Senator
Clinton I had five jobs I don't think
any of them lasted for six months and I
think a lot of people to tell you that
that's doing something wrong and maybe
it was but don't don't feel like you
have to do something and do it for five
years if it takes you five six jobs to
get to where you want to go so be it of
course this is all a huge
rationalization for my own career path
but standing here at this podium nearly
a decade after leaving this campus it
does seem to make perfect sense
everything happens for a reason and
nothing that has happened in my
professional political career could have
happened with what without what preceded
it and if the nine years since I
graduated from GS is any guide I I don't
have any idea where i'll be a year from
now any more than I knew a year ago I
would in the midst of what was just an
actual you know gut-wrenching set of
primaries that I'd have the honor of
working for the secretary of state of
the United States in support of
President Obama if you had told me that
a year ago I don't know what I would
have thought you were smoking but I
would not have you would be out of your
mind I don't hopefully I'll still be
there in a year but I know wherever i'll
be in a year it's someplace i would not
be without my time at general studies
there's not a day that goes by that I
don't think of and value my time here
you know most of you were many of you
don't know where you'll be a year from
now a lot of you might not even know
where you'll be a week from now but
trust me I've got a head start on all of
you and I know that wherever you go
wherever you end up the non-traditional
path you've taken as a path that will
serve you well after all you know
mountain climbers
zigzagging is the best way to make up a
steep climbs but sometimes the best way
to get between two points is anything
but a straight line the way the way I
see it you actually all have a leg up on
those that are graduating this month
from colleges across the country because
your experiences before and during your
time here will prove much more valuable
and important that you might even
realize in this moment so even what are
anxious times and even a time what many
of you don't know what's next I hope you
take a moment to appreciate how far
you've come how much you've achieved and
how ready you are absolutely ready you
are for what's next so those are three
traditional lessons I've broken and what
I've learned along the way but I guess I
it couldn't hurt to leave you just one
more piece of advice in your careers
education Xin lives none of you has
taken the traditional route my one piece
of advice is don't start now thank you
and congratulations to you all
Emily Holland was born in Massachusetts
into a bilingual French English family
she excelled in high school but when her
request for early graduation was denied
she left school without a diploma
determined to pursue learning her own
way she travelled through Europe
eventually returning to Cambridge where
she worked as a volunteer at the
Cambridge housing assistance fund and
other nonprofits during that time she
also became a dedicated yoga student
eventually becoming a skilled yoga
teacher herself Emily came to GS to
pursue her passion for international
relations especially Russian cultural
language and politics as a political
science major she served on the
editorial board of the Journal of
politics and society and worked as the
publication's deputy of the Columbia
political union her paper the Soviet
invasion of Afghanistan superpower
crisis and the cause of the second Cold
War period was selected by the
undergraduate history Council to be
published in its journal I'm delighted
to announce that emily has turned down
admission to Harvard Law School in order
to remain at Columbia to pursue a PhD in
political science Emily Holland
graduates with better than an a average
in political science summa laude Phi
Beta Kappa and as a member of the GS
Honor Society it is an absolute pleasure
for me to introduce to you the
salutatorian of the class of 2009 Miss
Emily Holland
I was worried when he didn't arrive that
there would just be a disembodied head
we came up here president Bollinger
provost Brinkley vice president Dirk's d
non-faculty friends mentors and teachers
I want to say how delighted I am to be
here this evening with all of my fellow
graduates and their friends and family
standing here this evening I am overcome
with the sense of accomplishment and
pride that I am sure is shared with all
of my fellow graduates this sense of
gratification at the completion of our
undergraduate studies is for me made
more poignant by the fact that mine was
not an easy road and took a number of
divergent paths along the way to this
point perhaps the most special thing
about our wonderful school of general
studies is that most all of us have
taken a journey along a long winding and
sometimes bumpy roads towards the
culmination of our college careers here
I've had the privilege of taking classes
and making friendships with the most
diverse group of people I have ever met
on my first day in my first class the
infamous University Writing I met a
group of new general studies students
whose diversity of pads truly amazed me
I became friends with the director of an
NGO a former Duke University student
turned bookstore manager a girl from
southeastern Texas working as a social
worker for underprivileged children and
a married father of two suddenly I who
had left school to travel europe work in
real estate and become a yoga teacher
did not seem so unusual that fall
semester all of us struggled together
over numerous drafts endless workshops
and countless hours at the computer to
work on the lens essay
in which we were asked to reinterpret a
moment in our live through the lens of
something completely different lately
with the nostalgia of graduation upon me
I've been thinking about that first
assignment and just how appropriate it
is to view our entire experience here at
Columbia through a lens I know that I as
well as many of my fellow graduates wear
many hats some balancing their studies
with full-time careers and jobs many as
parents and I as a student here and as a
yoga teacher three times a week I grab
my books and run for the subway after
class during that subway ride I quickly
change hats from student to teacher and
prepare to impart some of the wisdom I
have learned along the way as a student
of yoga master Baron Baptiste as a yoga
teacher you quickly come to the
realization that while you are a teacher
you are also a student learning from
other teachers and from your students as
well I begin every class greeting my
students and asking them to take a few
deep breaths to arrive on their mats and
in the present moment most new students
look at me like I'm speaking a foreign
language and so I ask them what they are
thinking about inevitably they are
thinking about the stressful day at work
an argument they had earlier the grocery
shopping they have to do on the way home
or the bills they have to pay tomorrow
almost none arrived in class thinking
about the present moment and how they
feel both physically and mentally right
now anticipation and rehearsing past
actions over and over in one's head is
not unusual here is college students in
my experience we rarely take time to
enjoy the present moment all of our
thoughts are constantly leaping ahead
anticipating deadlines fearing the
arrival of Grey's or more positively
looking forward towards graduation and
the completion of our studies of course
no one of these things is necessarily
bad in fact
anticipation of deadlines is quite
important as a student here and my
fellow graduates can attest there are
many of them and they arrive with
alarming frequency it is not a bad thing
to look forward to these days when we
are receiving in paper confirmation that
we have completed our studies the
Diploma we will receive on Wednesday is
indeed validation of all the incredibly
hard work we have put in towards
achieving the goal of graduating from
Columbia however all of the anticipation
and regret we have takes us away from
the most important thing we have all had
here the experience of being a student
at the school of general studies of
Columbia University I always ask my yoga
students to enjoy the present moment
because it is fleeting even when they
are breathing heavily muscled shaking
sweat pouring down their faces and
probably willing me to move on to
another pose I asked them to integrate
the experience because the moment is
short-lived it is the experience that
matters I tell them that while many of
them will never be able to touch the toe
to the back of their heads it's the
attempt that matters the experience of
trying that matters while we will all
walk away from here on Wednesday having
reached the goal of graduating from
Columbia it is the experience that
matters what really makes the difference
are all the owl's of toil on the
computer numerous sunny days spent in
butler library the satisfaction of
having a stat test and the great time
spent with friends it is the culmination
of these experiences that lead to this
moment when we are all able to reap the
benefits of our hard work I am
constantly amazed at how it is that the
people who struggle the most in my yoga
classes are the one who comes up to me
at the end of class saying they wished
it hadn't ended I am sure it is the same
for many of us now that it is over we
can look back and see just how wonderful
our experience at Columbia really was i
know i will never forget the good times
the friendships and all of the hard work
that led up to this
moment but I often wish I had been able
to heed the advice I give to my students
and have been aware all along and how
amazing it is to be here at Columbia
luckily for me I will have another
chance if I will be continuing here next
year studying for a graduate degree in
the Department of Political Science in
the same way all of my fellow graduates
will have this chance as I'm sure you
will take the experiences you have
encountered here with you wherever it is
you go this spring I had the pleasure of
taking a class with the professional
ballet dancer a former firefighter a
newly arrived immigrants from Armenia
and the instructor and assistant to the
UN Secretary General throughout the
semester I had the unique experience of
sharing classes ideas and thoughts about
the importance and consequences of
international intervention with such a
diverse group of people while this class
would no doubt had been informative and
enriching had there been no students
from the school of general studies it
would not have given me such a
real-world experience when dealing with
issues such as international
interventions that cross borders and
speak greatly to what it means to be
human a divergent chorus of voices and
thought with the cacophony of opinions
and different concerns is truly
important integrating the opinions of
others with your own ideas and concerns
is truly the only way to deal with the
problems we discuss in class and the
problems we will encounter once we leave
the 116 Street gates while my life may
not have taken a traditional path and at
times during the bumpiest patches along
the road I certainly never attack
expected to arrive here at such a
distinguished yet nurturing institution
columbia and the school of general
studies have shown me that in life truly
anything is possible they have
demonstrated to me that the primacy of
experience is truly the most rewarding
thing of all thank you very much and
congratulations
good evening my name is Scott Alverson
and I am the acting dean of students at
the school of general studies president
Bollinger provo sprinkly executive
vice-president Dierks dean on mr. Ramos
distinguished faculty dedicated alumni
and assembled guests is my privilege and
my very great pleasure resent to you one
by exceptional one our candidates for
The Bachelor of Arts or Bachelor of
Science in the school of general studies
class of two thousand nine
each degree candidate will receive a
certificate of achievement from
president Bollinger with this special
moment captured on film by a
photographer Deborah Marshall class of
nineteen seventy nine will then present
each graduate with the GS alumni pin
which we hope you wear with great pride
and affection now it is at this dramatic
moment in the program when the person
standing here is compelled to make the
most difficult administrative requests
of the year and in this job that's
saying something but we do ask we humbly
ask that you please hold your applause
until all the graduates have been
formally presented on stage for the
simple reason that we would not want one
family's enthusiasm to drown out the
presentation of another proud families
graduate I promise you ample time for
unbridled jubilation when the
presentation of the class of two
thousand nine is concluded thank you so
much for your understanding and
restraint with a few exceptions this
year's class will be presented in
alphabetical order approximately with
the candidates for the degree of
Bachelor of Arts and Bachelor of Science
draw near Pamela our Thiago Motta
bachelor of arts comparative literature
and society magna laude Henry Maddox
mccurdy bachelor of arts english summa
laude Gerard Patrick Carter bachelor
of arts French magna laude a
departmental honors Joanne Reynosa Rosa
bachelor of arts Hispanic studies
concentration education magna laude
Natalie Erin Johnston bachelor of arts
psychology summa laude departmental
honors David erin sander Minchin
Bachelor of Arts political science summa
laude Mary Ellen Feinberg bachelor
of arts history and theory of
architecture summa laude Carmen
Irene a burr bachelor of arts english
christine marie masters bachelor of arts
italian cultural studies magna laude
James Rudolph agra pop the fourth
bachelor of science neuroscience and
behavior magna laude Christina ray
gue lac's Bachelor of Arts political
science Nicole alejandra Abbott bachelor
of arts architecture Aaron Tyler elson
bachelor of arts political science Sofia
mariela a liberto bachelor of arts
economics Carolyn Leslie Allen bachelor
of arts english magna laude sheer
Ilan Bachelor of Arts comparative
literature in society departmental
honors joshua mark Altman bachelor of
arts political science magna laude
lauren nicole Bedrosian bachelor of arts
biological sciences summa laude
ariel david brennan bachelor of arts
english Marlene Arroyo bachelor of
science neuroscience and behavior Samuel
Benjamin Ashworth bachelor of arts
english marionette aneek and Atwater
bachelor of arts classical studies Evan
Derek bear bachelor of arts english
justine till Barnes bachelor of arts
economics Austin Cornelius dunam Barney
bachelor of arts East Asian Studies Olga
bosco bachelor of arts political science
the laude Timothy mark Beckman
Bachelor of Arts economics mathematics
richard albert Belva bachelor of arts
religion David Joseph Samuel bender
bachelor of arts history with a
concentration in computer science magna
laude Cheryl Allison Bourg Bachelor
of Arts political science Brody cburg
bachelor of science computer science
Leslie Renee Berman Bachelor of Arts
anthropology and dance summa laude a
departmental honors and anthropology and
dance Jonathan's v Berman billig
bachelor of arts history laude
chinmoy bought to charge a bachelor of
science physics jose luis blanco
bachelor of arts psychology Eleanor and
Clare Colley bachelor of arts history
slavic studies concentration in slavic
studies magna laude Emily Jennifer
Holland Bachelor of Arts political
science summa laude a departmental
honors david benjamin hilden bachelor of
arts anthropology summa laude a
departmental honors in anthropology
carlie christine curcio bachelor of arts
economics and political science
laude emek I Angelina's Boyer Bachelor
of Arts mathematics Erin Kendall Brown
bachelor of arts psychology magna
laude Tolan Brown bachelor of arts
history laude chose Shoshanna Sarah
Brownstein Bachelor of Arts sociology
Milan Angela Bruno bachelor of arts
economics
Brian Michael bull tice Bachelor of Arts
economics and operations research magna
laude adelbert ocampo bachelor of
arts mathematics Holly Larson capello
bachelor of science astronomy &
literature writing Heidi Laura blauvelt
bachelor of arts english mean ah Choi
bachelor of arts economics and
mathematics Deirdre Louise Chong
Bachelor of Arts sociology laude
Maria class bachelor of science
astronomy Jamie and diamond bachelor of
arts psychology Julie isabel de molen
bachelor of arts sociology laude
Gordon Oliver Elliot Bachelor of Arts
political science with a concentration
in history Elise firenzi bachelor of
arts psychology with a concentration in
education laude Jessica cotone
Bachelor of Arts and through pology
aires de la cruz bachelor of arts
anthropology laude Molly Jenna flink
bachelor of arts english Jacob m
Friedman bachelor of arts music and
religion Erica Gallegos bachelor of arts
political science Lucrezia Garcia Medina
bachelor of arts art history laude
jessica marie Garza bachelor of arts
sociology Madeline R Gleason Bachelor of
Arts visual arts
Brendan t goong-bok bachelor of science
neuroscience and behavior laude
Jessica unju negraph bachelor marks film
studies with departmental honors in film
studies David Paul Fishman Bachelor of
Arts psychology Jonathan grant bachelor
marks English Eric correo greeby
Bachelor of Arts anthropology magna
laude jaane granot bachelor of arts
philosophy under our mondo Guerra
bachelor of arts political science
Michael Anthony garyo bachelor of arts
Hispanic studies Jamie Leah guzzardo
bachelor of science evolutionary biology
of the human species laude Jung hee
ha bachelor of arts psychology summa
laude Jacqueline Amy Gerber bachelor of
science neuroscience and behavior Adrian
Elizabeth Herrera bachelor of arts
english and sociology Darren Kincaid
Harrison bachelor of science chemistry
Brian Thomas Hawthorne bachelor of arts
english summa laude katherine
elizabeth hayden bachelor of arts
sociology with a concentration in human
rights Sam Heinrich Bachelor of Arts
political science laude Jonathan
Simon Henken bachelor of arts history
laude laura michelle Hernandez
bachelor of arts literature writing
magna laude ken Christopher Hill
bachelor of arts english Rebecca Lee
Heiner bachelor of arts biological
sciences
Emily Hannah Haney coron Bachelor of
Arts psychology magna laude Devin
Campbell her an bachelor of arts art
history magna laude with
departmental honors in art history
sereth Raquel horwitz Bachelor of Arts
psychology magna laude rachel
Esterhaus bachelor of arts history with
a concentration in the pre medical
sciences John her Bachelor of Arts
economics and psychology you jean-luc
Wang bachelor of science biochemistry
with a concentration in mathematics
Sebastian Eduardo earwig awry bachelor
of arts history Nadia Bhanu Ishmael
Bachelor of Arts sociology Christopher
James Herrera Bachelor of Arts
anthropology magna laude with
departmental honors in anthropology
Keith jason douglas Hightower Bachelor
of Arts political science Jessamine rose
Theresa Jones Bachelor of Arts political
science magna laude Jared Paul
Jordan Bachelor of Science evolutionary
biology of the human species David Kagan
Bachelor of Arts American Studies magna
laude with departmental honors in
American Studies Peter Charles Kaminsky
Bachelor of Arts political science Brian
George Texan bachelor of arts history
Farrakhan bachelor of arts art history
Joseph golfer Bachelor of Arts
mathematics the concentration in pre
medical sciences laude Danielle
Ellen Jones Bachelor of Science
neuroscience and behavior and creative
writing soo Yeon kin
bachelor of arts East Asian Studies
michael klein bachelor of arts history
and philosophy magna laude katherine
m nitin bachelor of arts anthropology
with a concentration in education
Larissa calls nikova bachelor of arts
history laude Razi Mohammed Khan a
bachelor of arts architecture Trevor
Walton khoob bachelor of arts biological
sciences Pharisee portion Bachelor of
Arts anthropology Veronica Rita Hawker
bachelor of science neuroscience and
behavior magna laude peter s kim
bachelor of arts political science Scott
William Morrison bachelor of arts
political science laude knowest
aaron levitt bachelor of arts history
catalina lee bachelor of arts political
science christopher lens bachelor of
arts art history christopher michael
Libby bachelor of arts and through Paula
ge1 limb Bachelor of Arts psychology
summa laude jacqueline marie
Beckwith Bachelor of Arts Middle East
and Asian languages and cultures dana
rachel cresyl bachelor of arts history
Rachel Gail Lipsky bachelor of arts
psychology with a concentration in the
pre medical sciences John Weston Lockard
bachelor of arts economics mathematics
laude David Thomas Lafleur bachelor
of arts economics malka s Lowenstein
bachelor of arts German literature and
cultural history Yvonne McKinley
bachelor of arts biological sciences
George Justin Malone Bachelor of Arts
political science magna laude
departmental honors and political
science Maria markova bachelor of arts
philosophy albert kim bachelor of arts
economics mathematics laude Eleazar
Schindler layman Bachelor of Arts
religion magna laude Benedict
William Moser bachelor of arts history
Melissa and Muller Bachelor of Arts
Middle East and Asian languages and
cultures magna laude Todd Jerome
Murphy Bachelor of Arts ancient studies
archaeology laude Yuri nakashima
Bachelor of Arts sociology Philip
Rockwell non tell bachelor of arts
history Sarah Beckett bachelor of
science evolutionary biology of the
human species magna laude with
departmental honors in evolutionary
biology of the human species then dita
Scylla tani Crippen ed Bachelor of Arts
visual arts Sean Eric McMorris Bachelor
of Arts political science magna
laude with departmental honors in
political science Michael James Novak
bachelor of arts dance magna laude
with departmental honors in dance
Ishmael edite-o sake gray Bachelor of
Arts sociology zoria ospina Bachelor of
Arts economics Jennifer Jennifer Sarah
page bachelor of arts english Vivian
Maria pap bachelor of arts english juban
Park Bachelor of Arts East Asian Studies
Michael park bachelor of arts economics
Dana Melissa Alexander Bachelor of Arts
economics and political economics
political science Jacob F metal ski bats
Bachelor of Arts political science magna
laude with departmental honors in
political science Molly olap any
bachelor of arts sociology Matthew
hunter Platt bachelor of arts history
Rebecca Leia poll bachelor of arts music
Adrian Elizabeth price bachelor of arts
philosophy with a concentration in human
rights Kim rashanna wrapkin bachelor of
arts english magna laude nathaniel
mark richman bachelor of arts
anthropology laude Allison Rachel
Miller bachelor of arts psychology magna
laude Robert Charles Morehead
bachelor of science astrophysics song
chick park bachelor of science
biochemistry anna maria rivera bachelor
of arts english juan carlos rodriguez
bachelor marks economics philosophy
Lucas Fernando Romero obando bachelor of
arts biological sciences Ariela Josefa
Rosen bachelor of arts psychology magna
laude Erin gershon Rotenberg
bachelor of arts psychology and creative
writing magna laude with
departmental honors in creative writing
Robert Ralph Rove in ski bachelor of
arts english laude amita yariv flyer
bachelor of arts music laude
Antoinette Vaux bachelor of arts
philosophy Jenna Kalin polesky bachelor
of arts creative writing with a
concentration in English summa laude
a departmental honors in creative
writing elizabeth g
horn Bachelor of Arts sociology ashkan
chiavari bachelor of arts political
science jennifer marie Shannon bachelor
of science physics dennis michael
shepherd bachelor of arts creative
writing Carly Anne Siegel bachelor of
arts anthropology may ROVs shulem eat
seagull Richmond Bachelor of Arts
psychology Natasha parish bachelor of
arts psychology Tyler Frederick Peterson
bachelor of arts art history Michael
postal barons Levine Schwartz bachelor
of arts economics ana carolina slow sir
bachelor of arts art history with a
concentration in history nyomi Smith
bachelor of arts Hispanic studies amico
so ikawa bachelor of arts creative
writing lauren nicole Steinberg bachelor
of arts political science laude
Garth Stewart bachelor of arts history
Felicia Stephanie story bachelor of arts
anthropology with a concentration in
human rights Mary M Street cyl bachelor
of arts english with a concentration in
sociology laude michael jeffery rain
bachelor of arts political science
samuel Bennett Rena Boehm bachelor of
arts comparative ethnic studies summa
laude with departmental honors and
comparative ethnic studies Matthew
Blaine Thompson bachelor of science
neuroscience and behavior Emily Petra
lack Thompson Bachelor of Arts
psychology volha saw helmick bachelor of
arts economics
Daniel Richard Tyner Brian bachelor of
arts psychology laude Marguerite
Jane Hillary van cook bachelor of arts
english magna laude mercedes varna
ghee bachelor of arts psychology lane
douglas cell bachelor of arts classics
for the concentration in the visual arts
Patrick Griffith see more bachelor of
arts economics Jacob Joseph Tabor
bachelor of arts history magna laude
Matthew's bhatt amala bachelor of arts
art history with departmental honors in
art history Alexander Patrick Antoine v
all bachelor of arts architecture Erica
Monique Victor bachelor of arts
sociology male Itza fly kovitch bachelor
of arts film studies magna laude
with departmental honors in film studies
gori Satish wobble Bachelor of Arts
theoretical neuroscience summa laude
Joshua Weinberg bachelor of science
computer science magna laude michael
Noah Weissman bachelor of arts english
thomas james russell bachelor of arts
history nancy jane saunders bachelor of
arts political science David sergeant
wis well bachelor of arts english Nicole
Aaron yerushalmi bachelor of arts
psychology with a concentration in the
pre medical sciences magna laude
matthew Caruso Stouffer bachelor of arts
music laude Barami Yoon bachelor of
arts economics Caillou a valley bachelor
of arts economics mathematics some me we
bachelor of arts economics
Matthew h10 Bachelor of Arts economics
with a concentration in art history
Gabriella Joan Tyson Bachelor of Arts
creative writing thomas william westfall
bachelor of arts psychology laude
Marlene our gamez Garcia bachelor of
arts economics political science
laude helaina lellis bachelor of arts
economics Katie metra belly bachelor of
arts political science ocn Patrick Foley
Bachelor of Arts laude a
departmental honors and creative writing
katarzyna zofia mellow Bachelor of Arts
political science Dennis Charles
Griffith bachelor of arts english
Sheamus Patrick Barrett bachelor of arts
political science Darren Scott Stewart
bachelor of arts history and political
science IRA Brian stoop Bachelor of Arts
American Studies magna laude Jacob
Alexander green bachelor of arts music
laude Harry Scott small oatts
bachelor of arts english by haha nice
young bachelor of arts economics magna
laude Brendan allsburg McQueen
bachelor of arts film studies Haim
lazzaro's bachelor of arts film studies
young jang jae bachelor of arts
economics william john richard Wetzel
bachelor of arts political science for
the concentration and sustainable
development magna laude Jessica
Michelle Willis bachelor of arts english
laura marie sharik bachelor of arts
economics summa laude Benjamin Noah
Ernst bachelor of arts philosophy Talia
Christine Verona's Pablo palace bachelor
of arts classic summa laude Melissa
van bachelor of arts political science
Daniel mark whiner bachelor of arts
computer science mathematics with a
concentration in the pre medical
sciences summa laude segi Goldenberg
bachelor of science neuroscience and
behavior summa laude
well the class of 2009 please rise
president Bollinger
president Bollinger provost Brinkley
executive vice president Dirk's been on
distinguished faculty GS alumni
cherished friends and family members I
am absolutely delighted to formally
present you the general studies class of
two thousand nine
members of the class of 2009 assembled
here are many of the people who have
supported you and sacrifice with you
during the pursuit of your Columbia
degree they are here today to celebrate
with you now let us take a moment to
celebrate them as well please be seated
Dean andreas Solomon will now present
academic awards and prizes
members of the class of 2009 you've
distinguished yourselves in myriad ways
as impressive scholars members of the
Columbia community and citizens of the
world this evening we would like to
single out a few of our graduates for
special recognition as recipients of GS
Awards established by generous alumni
and friends of the school of general
studies these prizes acknowledge
academic excellence and extraordinary
leadership those students honored today
should rise when their names are called
and via the nearest stairs come on stage
to receive their award we are very proud
of you for an outstanding scholar who
exemplifies the society's ideal of
intellectual integrity the Phi Beta
Kappa prize is awarded to David Hilden
for distinction in English and
comparative literature the professor
John Angus Burrell memorial prize is
awarded to Henry max mccurdy for a
junior with promising talent and
sociology media or journalism the albert
ii golan prize is awarded to antoinette
Barry for excellence in the study of
sociology the loo Lillian L hacker prize
is awarded in absentia to Lena Friedrich
for distinction in Italian studies that
Benedetto morado prize is awarded to
Gerard Carter
for excellence in Italian Studies the
medallion otter prize is awarded to
Christine masters
for excellence in Spanish the doctor
Antonio g Meyer prize is awarded to
Johann Reynosa Rosa for excellence in
the study of psychology the Jennifer a
pack prize is awarded to Natalie
Johnston and you beat such admin
for excellence in political science the
Arthur Ross foundation award goes to
Emily Holland and David Minchin
for outstanding contributions in art
history archaeology the Judith least
ronak memorial prize is awarded to Mary
Ellen Feinberg
the Dean citation is awarded to a
graduating senior who has distinguished
himself or herself through service to
the GS Columbia community this year we
are delighted to have two recipients of
the Dean citation mr. aires de la cruz
and mr. peter kim
so just stay right here Aries dela Cruz
leave the lasting legacy at Columbia
because of his tireless tireless efforts
as a bridge builder among disparate
groups in the undergraduate community
and his influential leadership roles on
and off campus from his position on the
Editorial Board of the Columbia
spectator to his work as vice president
of the queer alliance with involvement
in New Student Orientation peer
mentoring various student literary
magazines and as peer educator and
development intern at a major HIV
prevention nonprofit in New York aires
de la cruz has demonstrated the core
humane values embodied in a Columbia
education for the coming summer Ares has
been awarded a fellowship with the
world's largest public relations firm to
work on advocacy and corporate social
responsibility in the fall he will begin
his master's in public administration at
a university downtown that will remain
nameless congratulations Aries
just great
Peter Kim has been immensely influential
as president of the Columbia University
military veterans organization known as
mil vets he has partnered with senior
administrators to improve veteran
services on campus create the veteran
war memorial on display in butler
library and create the university
website for student veterans that will
be launched this summer equally
important peter has been instrumental in
ensuring the participation of the entire
university in the new GI bill known as
the Yellow Ribbon Program as of today 13
columbia schools have signed on with GS
taking the lead as a concrete sign of
peter's commitment to veterans of
columbia he's just returned from a
recruiting trip with dean curtis rogers
during which they were invited to
conduct GS information sessions at three
major military installations on the west
coast Peter's tireless and unselfish
approach to all veteran students
regardless of school is the hallmark of
his true leadership abilities the next
several months peter will continue to
work in consulting while he seeks
permanent employment with the department
of state congratulations Peter
so crowded
each year the Alumni Keys the soap
bestowed on one or more seniors who have
achieved distinction academically and
through service to the school miss
Deborah Marshall class of 1979 will
present the award to this year's
recipients the choice is Helen Everett's
I polisher miss help Helen Everett class
of nineteen seventy and the winner of
the alumni metal will present the award
this year the choice was particularly
difficult since so many graduating
seniors have distinguished themselves
both as scholars and as members of the
Columbia community I'm particularly
grateful to the work of the GS student
council under the presidency of Brody
Berg and to Carly Curcio Melissa van and
albert kim for their efforts to
encourage participation in the senior
gift this year the Alumni key is awarded
to iris stoop and Daniel whiner
iris 2 is a graduating senior in the
joint program between Columbia GS and
list college of the jewish theological
seminary students in the joint program
earned two bachelor's degrees in four
years one at Columbia the other at list
college iris tubes extraordinary impact
has been felt in both communities he
served as one of the coordinators of the
first alternative spring break trips
dedicated to building coalitions between
Jewish students and students of color
for the past four years he has organized
Columbia's anti-hate leadership summit
for high school leaders aimed at
building safer schools free of violence
and discrimination he's been a leader at
Columbia Hillel working with with campus
and local groups to support progressive
Jewish religious and political life but
the past year has been a peer counselor
at Columbia's health services helping
students navigate issues of sexual
health at the same time he's excelled in
his academic work both at Columbia and
at lyst college he is the recipient of a
fellowship from humanity and action
which will take him to Poland this
summer where he will study minority
rights in contemporary polish society
he's also been awarded a door or
fellowship in Israel the fellowship
focuses on developing a network of
Jewish lay leaders to address renewal
and social change in the American Jewish
community iris tube graduates magna
laude in American Studies Phi Beta Kappa
and as a member of the GS Honor Society
congratulations
Daniel winer has combined work in
computer science mathematics and free
medical studies while maintaining a full
engagement in the life of GS and
Columbia he served for three years on
the faculty student committee that
oversees all academic programs for GS
students he was heavily involved as an
orientation leader for seven terms and a
peer mentor he gave presentations to
incoming students on digital resources
and managing your digital life at
Columbia he's volunteered at the Mount
Sinai School of Medicine in there p ET
lab and at the columbia university
medical center in the center for
interventional vascular therapy research
he's volunteered at a trauma unit been a
volunteer HIV educator next year Daniel
will be working in various capacities at
mount sinai medical center while he
applies to medical school Daniel winer
graduate summa laude in computer
science and mathematics Phi Beta Kappa
and as a member of the GS Honor Society
congratulations
you
david hilden was born in Alaska raised
in Botswana and Kenya with one year in
between in Fargo North Dakota almost all
of David's early education was in Africa
especially Nairobi where he attended
rosslyn Academy an avid internationalist
and drama buff David spent his high
school years acting in school
productions to great acclaim and
becoming one of the driving forces
behind the Model United Nations after
graduation from high school in two
thousand David moved to Richmond while
his family remained in Kenya David soon
discovered the delights of waiting
tables and living on the margins of
American society he was so good at
waiting tables however that he won a
national award from Richmond he moved to
Miami where he continued to explore the
America that he had never known growing
up in 2004 David moved to San Diego
where he continued to wait tables while
he attended San Diego City College in
2005 David began his Columbia career
spending his first summer in Thailand
where his family now lives and doing
anthropological research among an
indigenous tribal group in Cambodia and
South Vietnam after a second year he
spent the summer in Guatemala improving
his Spanish and feasting on Central
American culture in his last summer at
Columbia David took two internships one
at Covenant House the other at Freedom
House while waiting tables full time
at one of New York's trendiest
restaurants during the academic year
David performed at a breathtakingly high
level in every course he attempted but
especially in the field of anthropology
in many ways David is an anthropological
experiment himself he has lived all over
the world he's climbed Mount Kilimanjaro
worked as a telemarketer started his own
business importing African artworks
worked as a hospitality trainer in the
restaurant industry helped start build
and operate a coffee house in Kenya and
perhaps the best delighted in water
skiing in a lake grossly infested with
hippos if you're looking for the epitome
of the non-traditional student look no
farther if you are looking for a
passionate internationalist and
brilliant anthropologist look no farther
if you are looking for a man committed
to making a difference in the world look
no farther David Hilden graduates with
better than an a average in anthropology
summa laude Phi Beta Kappa winner of
the Phi Beta Kappa prize and member of
the GS Honor Society for the next two
years David will be working for Teach
for America in the Mississippi Delta it
is a true privilege to present to you
the valedictorian of the class of 2009
mr. David Hilden
Thank You Dean on I want to start off by
welcoming everyone here again to the
general studies class day of 2009 thank
you so much for coming president
Bollinger Provost Brinkley executive
vice president Dirk's Dean on all of our
great Dean's faculty members staff
family and friends and most importantly
you the general studies graduating class
of 2009 we made it and I don't have to
tell everyone here that 4gs students
this is huge and probably somewhat
unexpected but better late than never am
i right mom dad I was really excited
when I found out that I would get to
speak at my college graduation until I
realized that it meant I would have to
speak at my college graduation I spent
weeks agonizing over how to begin this
speech so like any good Columbia student
I began with some internet research
wikipedia
wikipedia usually my best friend was a
big waste of time Google Scholar took me
down a long road to nowhere youtube on
the other hand was a jackpot or so it
seemed at the time the thousands of hits
i received from my search for
valedictorian speeches nearly yielded
excited 18 year old high school seniors
waxing poetic on finally reaching the
crossroads of their lives moving on to
the independence of college dorm rooms
and eventually with some hard work the
columbia college class day tomorrow
after watching about 20 of these
speeches i saw that there really is
something to the idea that GS students
don't fit the regular mold that made me
realize i can't turn to any sort of
typical valedictory speech for the
school of general studies we are who we
are in gray part because we did not
follow the standard pass that those
giddy 18 year olds were about to embark
on we chose differently and this is what
i want to focus on today those choices
are what make us who we are as GS
students and set us apart from all the
others graduating around the world this
year so let me begin were all our
different paths finally crossed at
orientation I remember breaking open my
box lunches my new advisor was
introducing himself I was privileged
enough to have Dean stellini the first
thing he said was that he was sure we
were thinking there had been some sort
of mistake in the admissions process he
was right I had all sorts of doubts
about my ability to compete at an Ivy
League school he assured us that this
was not the case and that we were all
Columbia material so after Cellini's a
little pep talk I was feeling pretty
good and began to believe I really could
compete with the best of these young
brain
X then all that confidence came crashing
down around me my first day of
university writing I walked in thinking
I was special thinking I was a good
writer and had nothing to learn from
some mandatory writing class I mean I
took honors english 101 and 102 at my
Community College what could University
Writing teach me then on our first day
of class we were going around the room
introducing ourselves and as if it was
normal one guy said the word
tautological and suddenly in one fell
swoop every bit of confidence that had
puffed up my head like a balloon was let
out what did tautological mean why
weren't the other students looking
around baffled at this at this
mysterious word I was sunk it was over I
had bitten off way more than I could
chew but with the help of another GS
student from my old community college I
learned that word and many more before
the class was over tautology for those
of you now going through the same thing
I did is the needless repetition of an
idea something I hope to avoid over the
next few minutes but anyway that's how I
know that Dean Cellini was right we all
made it through that class and
distinguished ourselves and many others
we adapted to our new situation here
Columbia and we accomplish things even
we may have thought were not possible i
know i did I know I Oh Jim a big one for
his help in my university writing class
and Sarah for help my last semester but
I'm proud of that two gs has taught me
to be humble and to ask for help when I
need it and to learn from those who are
wiser than me and yes sometimes that was
the kid sitting next to me who was I
still can't believe it
born in the 90s but getting back to this
idea of choices one of the things that
has always impressed me the most about
GS students is the fascinating stories
that you all have you are unique group
that represents what is possible if you
really strive for your dreams I want to
tell you about a good buddy of mine
Devin sitting out there with you
graduates right now I think what he did
really simplifies the spirit and heart
of the GS student body we were talking
once arguing really about films in a
greatest movie of all time I say dumb
and dumber he fervently disagrees but
anyway he was going on about his
favorite director some obscure
Lithuanian guy who makes films you can
hardly even find here in the States he
told me his dream would be to work with
this director or even just to meet him
so a couple of years ago instead of
summer school I suggested he take a trip
maybe even to Lithuania since he's
always talking about it and maybe he
would run into this guy well he went
ahead and did it and he took it one step
further he found this directors address
and showed up on his doorstep sure
enough I got an email from him telling
me he had met the director and was hired
on to help him film his next movie and
this is what i mean by choices devin
didn't choose to take film classes over
the summer instead he went to lithuania
as GS students we deeply value our time
in the classroom but we also appreciate
the lessons garnered from taking
uncommon paths from making uncommon
choices we learn differently we achieve
differently but the end result is that
we make it happen and that is what is
going to be important our bold choices
like the ones that put us here today and
these caps and gowns prove that we can
have control in shaping our own lives
however there are always obstacles to
success and this brings me to something
I have to mention because I know it's on
all of our minds we are graduating in
one of the worst economy since our
grandparents time jobs are not easy to
come by and as GS students we enter this
economy even further burnin by dead yet
I still believe that this class of 2009
will continue to defy the norms and
succeeded miss adversity we did not come
here because we were forced to but
because we chose to and we have been
rewarded with one of the best college
education as possible with our wide
variety of backgrounds unique
experiences and the knowledge we now
have we know that we are capable of
great things standing here today you all
are evidence that your dreams can be
fulfilled no matter what the odds we all
know that the vast majority of those do
not go on to college right after high
school or unlikely to ever achieve a
bachelor's degree but here we are with
families with different professional
backgrounds an average age of 29 and
graduating from one of the best
universities in the world we do not fit
the model of the average Ivy League
student but we rose to the challenges
before us and made the choices necessary
to succeed I think that is what defines
gia students though we may not all know
what tautological means and we may be a
little different from those around us we
can adapt to our situations and
accomplish things even we may have
thought were not possible i know that
before i started back to school my poor
parents were always stuck having to come
up with creative ideas to tell friends
and family when they were asked the
question so how is david doing after
graduating from high school my parents
very well couldn't just turn around and
say well he's exploring himself and
living in a tent in miami but you know
what it is our unique and yes sometimes
tough experiences that brought us to
columbia with a hunger for knowledge and
a
to learn this insatiable drive is what
has helped us succeed here and is what
will help us succeed in the future so as
my speech this ceremony and our time
here Columbia come to closed I am
reminded of a Swahili proverb from Kenya
where I spent most of my childhood elimu
nanamia Timbo IE she directly translated
means education is the meat of an
elephant it never finishes
that is if you imagine sitting down to
eat all of an elephant you realize that
it is not something you could finish in
a short while but something you would
eat over a whole lifetime and that is
one of the things that we know best at
GS our time at Columbia is not our
entire education it is part of our
education there is still so much of the
elephant left so class of 2009 as we go
on after today as Columbia graduates I
have faith that we will continue to find
our dreams through uncertain paths I
have faith that we will succeed at the
things we sell to do and continue to
voraciously seek out knowledge ever
learning more about the world around us
my fellow graduates as we walk out of
here today I encourage you to choose
boldly to choose wisely and to never
forget that today is simply another
example of how we can overcome the odds
and fulfill our greatest dreams class of
2009 it was a privilege to be here at
Columbia with you and I am proud to
stand with you here today thank you and
God bless
congratulations to the graduates your
family's loved ones and friends I would
especially like to congratulate the
senior class for their commitment to the
mission and ideals of GS and Columbia I
invite you all to continue the
celebration at the class a reception to
be held under the tent on the lawn in
front of Hamilton Hall directly to your
right I ask our guests to remain seated
while the president while the
president's party and the candidate file
out will the candidates please stand